we are also you know making sure that we
ship the best products for
both restaurants and and suppliers so i
don't believe that it's a trade-off that
we need to decide between one and the
other i think my job and my co-founders
job is
it's one or two if you want to put it
that way keep on having the best
profiles who are better than us
and then the second thing really
empowering them to keep on building
products and projects that will allow
katu to get better
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel an in media
partnership with c-tech
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today i am being joined by diogo
kuna co-founder and ceo of katu
diogo is a portuguese operator turned
founder after starting his career at
boston consulting group in spain diogo
joined uber on the driver growth team
for spain italy portugal and croatia he
launched these cities increased driver
conversion by 50 and more and led
efforts for the launch of new products
he's a travel fanatic has been to more
than 65 countries and is always looking
for the best street food wherever he
goes
diogo kunia welcome to 20 minute leaders
all the way from portugal how are you
hey michael it's great to be here i'm
great what about yourself
i'm doing great thank you very much for
taking the time to be here with me i'm
really excited to talk to you about your
own journey but specifically about about
your startup catholic i hope i'm saying
it correctly but dealing with
restaurants and suppliers and the
relationship there and i mean and you
know obviously i'm fascinated by the
restaurant industry a lot of people are
and i'm and i'm really interested in
diving deep into you know what it's like
to run a restaurant but from you know
more of the management perspective and
what are some of the challenges and the
gaps that you've discovered in examining
this vertical so dillo maybe tell me a
little bit about yourself and how you
came to
work in the restaurant space yeah so
very very shortly so
like i told you before i'm originally
portuguese
i ended up moving to spain five years
ago if i'm not mistaken to do to do
consulting at boston consulting group
where i worked with my co-founder
actually the two of us know each other
from before because we also worked
together in london so you know big
coincidence that we ended up working
together twice but still and so there
did a lot of different projects but
actually one of the
one of the ones that i liked the most
was uh for a very large quick service
restaurant chain that you know was about
to be acquired by a private equity group
that's how i first got into the
wrestling in this industry then a couple
of years later um i was at uber uh on
the driver acquisition team for portugal
spain italy and croatia also had a lot
of fun but that's mostly when i started
you know falling in love with operations
and really making things work in in big
industries where there's a huge problem
and so back in the days when we were at
pcg my co-founder and i mean we were
working for these really big
corporations and you know
we were a bit obsessed about the fact
that these corporations had to serve
their employees but in most cases they
were in remote places in the middle you
know like typical 25 kilometers away
from madrid
and the catering services there were
very limited and you know delivery was
not such a huge
thing back in 2017
and it wouldn't really you know even in
those cases food wouldn't get there so
we looked at each other and we said okay
let's open a dark kitchen
where we focus on servicing you know on
like almost like a catering company for
large um enterprises in spain that they
would then subsidize for their own
employees as part of their sort of
benefit plans
and so the first thing and just for
clarification dark kitchen would mean
not having a physical store but having
just the kitchen as sort of a back-end
service exactly
to cook more cheaper so we didn't mean
so much like creating an actual
restaurant inside these enterprise
campuses which a lot of companies do and
it's a super successful model so i'm not
sure you know banco santander one of the
largest banks in the world
the largest in spain so they have a
campus with you know it's just
it's gigantic they even have a golf
course inside their campus in madrid and
so they have a lot of restaurants inside
out of which a couple are you know
operated by companies who have also
russians in the city center but we
wanted a different approach we wanted
something that you know people you would
leave in different buildings so sort of
a dark kitchen inside these campuses and
then for the smaller ones at our kitchen
in the center which would then
distribute to these
and at that moment we were looking for
the amazon between restaurants and
suppliers you know in our sort of naive
way and we didn't find it so we started
deep diving into the space like who does
what you know what are the main problems
what are the main points uh pain points
and we found out that there was a huge
opportunity there and so we started
doing it a couple of years later but uh
and so walk me through some of the first
steps of of you researching the industry
and realizing okay there's a there's
this need there's this gap and and the
solution that you're bringing to the
restaurant scene yeah okay that's that's
a very good question so the first step
to us was very clear i mean someone must
be doing this somewhere right and so we
started deep diving at who does what i
mean have a lot of friends doing vc and
so we were really trying to understand
because after all i think a founder
cannot fall in love with a solution
founder can fall in love with the
problem and so who out there is trying
to solve this problem and we saw a lot
of different models i mean we saw a
couple of people that were doing the
farm-to-table models in the u.s there's
a super famous one called cheetah we saw
a couple of people that directly wanted
to open the marketplace so you know like
uh you get suppliers and you get and you
get
and you get restaurants on the other
side and you try for them to communicate
and then we were seeing people trying to
solve this in a sort of different
approach which is trying to
use suppliers to get to more restaurants
but what was failing was that you know
after all if you're
basically trying to ensure a
communication tool between restaurants
and suppliers but you only work with x
number of suppliers you end up not
developing a good enough tool because
restaurants you know they can only order
to two or three suppliers through that
so you're just an extra complication big
marketplace yes so we inverted the
equation what we said was look why don't
we simply you know a bit like a dog
chasing cars why don't we just create an
amazing tool for restaurants we don't
really know where this is heading but we
basically start with a tool that
substitutes their classic excel
templates and through which they can
order to all of their suppliers the
beauty about it is that you get great
engagement but more than anything is
that you get your food into the
restaurant store and so you can start
really understanding you know
what are the main problems how does it
really work how does it work on the
other side so that was the first thing
we didn't need the suppliers to be on
the platform in the sense that we were
just creating a super easy to use tool
for restaurants that you know would
allow them to order in a much faster
error-free way that would then send an
email to the suppliers this was the
first step and how we start
then as we started you know
do you want me to tell you the second
process or the second part and then as
we started developing the tool
what happens is that you know
you have these suppliers that for three
months have been receiving emails saying
uh restaurant x powered by katu no and
they start coming to us and they're like
who are you you know
what is this katoo thing like do you
have anything for us
and that was the second step we said
well we don't yet but we are developing
it so let's sit down together and let's
see you know how we can really help you
and that is the second video so just to
make sure that i understood that i
understood correctly and diogo the the
idea was that you're gonna be you're
gonna allow restaurants to see
who the suppliers are without them yet
enrolling into the the platform ordering
from them through you and it's not
actually placing an order it's but it's
it's more of like an entire letter of
intent right a request
for fulfillment and then you're actually
getting the two-sided marketplace
without having to get both sides
enrolled in the solution yes but with
their current suppliers so there's no
discovery component involved already
it's the same thing as to say you know
all the cool productivity tools that are
now where you can basically send
messages through twilio it's the same
thing if the
as if i have sort of an excel powered by
twilio that sends an email to the
supplier
got it got it okay very very cool and
and that's so so you're not you're not
necessarily helping them discover new
suppliers but you're helping streamline
their communication with existing
suppliers you're finding product market
fit and saying okay we're we're figuring
out how to best have the communication
between restaurant and suppliers and
then you're going to deal with the
discovery and the second phase precisely
to me it's really about beautiful
believing that if you own the buyers and
you create a tool that they keep on
coming back and they keep on coming
using but especially a tool that is you
know it's
a very important part of the backbone of
the restaurant like
i want i won't go as far as to say that
it's easy to create a tool that
increases revenue for wrestlers but the
value proposition is super clear and the
problem is that chern ends up being high
in a lot of cases but if you create a
tool that really becomes an essential
part of the day to day of the restaurant
from which they order to all of their
suppliers then your possibilities are
limitless i mean our
three months churn for example is below
five percent our our you know our gmv
cohorts are incredibly healthy and and
it's just the fact that you know it has
a viral effect because the referral
rates are just insane and we don't pay
anything for that so it's really you
know our obsession was becoming a tool
that restaurants really love and keep on
using and keep on coming back and when
i'm in restaurants i don't mean about
you know the stanford guy that uh all of
a sudden opened um a restaurant chain
because he liked tacos
i mean the classical chef who's normally
non-tech savvy normally has you know
facebook and perhaps whatsapp on their
phone which is widely popular in europe
i know that not so much in the states so
it's really about creating a tool for
them that they love and then start
building from them on that's our whole
mentality but like i was telling you
before the thing is that the suppliers
are getting our emails you know and with
that they start coming to us and they
say hey getting your emails is already a
lot better than receiving you know the
messy voicemails that i used to receive
at 4am because you need to remember that
the way that things are normally done is
chef closes the kitchen
and walks through his sort of
not the warehouse but the kitchen
calling suppliers one by one and leaving
voicemail
and they normally don't say bring me
two boxes of four kilos each of tomato
but i want cherry tomato they say hi
bring me two of them
and the following day at four a.m you
get into a supplier's office and there
are
five ten people with headphones all day
long listening to voicemails and
translating these by manually inputting
data on an erp
at katu we are turbo charging their
operations by you know connecting their
erp with a mobile app that we have so
the step at which we are now and
suppliers came to us asking us for this
is you know why do you need that sort of
data entry why don't we connect with the
suppliers erp and we allow number one
for that data entry to be completely
extinguished in the sense that it was
directly into their erp
mistakes to be solved because you know
the catalog it's automatically updated
by what's available on the erb or not
and same thing goes for pricing and last
but not least even though we don't allow
discovery as of yet through new
suppliers what we do allow is discovery
on your current supplier what you know
what else does your supplier have to
offer you so what we are doing now is
you know really focusing on building the
best sort of crm between suppliers and
restaurants and their existing
relationships just making sure that it
flows flawlessly no mistakes fast
efficient and in a nice way which i
think is very important
and so what what is the next phase in in
this scene it sounds that you've you've
really hit the nail on on helping you
know restaurant chefs streamline their
process of requesting the requesting
those supplies and you've it's been very
meaningful for the suppliers to be able
to
consist to get to get the request in a
consistent and in an easy to understand
format
what what is the next level of this game
so i think i mean there's a lot of
different layers one of the ones that i
think is right i do believe in the power
of automating this even further on the
restaurant side so i really believe that
we can go into a step where you know we
do predictive ordering we do something
that as of now is only seen in sort of
like
erps for large corporations we want to
democratize this and really make it a
reality for restaurants for them to be
more efficient and save even further on
costs we are already halfway there but
we will double down on this and on the
supplier side we really
want to ensure that we also help them i
mean with two different things number
one that we bring that sort of
intelligence especially with perishable
products for which they are for example
overstock like you know
for you doesn't it make sense for
example if if these pairs are are
getting bad doesn't it make sense for
you to actually do a broadcast to all of
your customers at the 50 cut because you
just need to sell this and that is one
and then the second one which we are
getting more and more into is you know
i'm an obscure i'm very focused on
getting ops right and it's really for
example the whole invoicing and
financing part it's an absolute mess
there's so much to be done there and we
need to continue all on evolving towards
this direction really becoming the
number one customer relation tool for
suppliers to interact with their
restaurant but in the very very long
term the vision is very clear i mean i'm
a big believer that in 2050 kitchens
will be something that will practically
only exist in in the for the wealthy
people you know they're expensive from a
real estate uh standpoint and then
i'm an economist i i lived in singapore
when i was young and i'm not sure you've
been to singapore but it's cheaper to
eat out in food hocks rather than
cooking at home
and to me as an economist yeah it makes
sense like why are people cooking
and so if we believe that the world is
walking towards that direction we must
empower veterans and suppliers to
interact in a much more efficient way so
that the food supply chain becomes
cheaper
more efficient and more transparent for
everyone that is where we are going
towards it's just that we are starting
by solving a small part of the equation
and today you're you're starting this
base out of madrid
and so is there is there a plan to
expand horizontally geographically to
other locations is there a plan to
expand vertically into a deeper into a
deeper relationship and and solve more
problems for the restaurants versus er
versus suppliers and what are sort of
the trade-offs that you're thinking
through as you're deciding strategically
what to do both uh so actually we're
doing both um so we are already in three
countries and will open between two and
three more until uh june next year
and then the second component which i
think it's important is we are also you
know making sure that we ship the best
products for both restaurants and and
suppliers so i don't believe that it's a
trade-off that we need to decide between
one and the other i think my job and my
co-founders job is
it's one or two if you want to put it
that way keep on having the best
profiles who are better than us
and then the second thing really
empowering them to keep on building
products and projects that will allow
katu to get better like the strategic
direction and the north star is one that
doesn't mean that cannot there cannot be
you know many projects inside the
company that allow us to go at the speed
of light which is how we need to go i
don't believe that we need to choose
between one and the other you know
especially now in an environment where
the market is full of capital i think
that our job as founders is to be
ambitious enough to know that we don't
need to choose between one and the other
is to know that we must go at full speed
right and so
you know looking back at you know the
the the two-setter marketplace and your
entrance uh into the restaurant scene
well what what are some non-trivial
things that came about
that you discovered that you know
perhaps the average person who just
enjoys going to restaurants wouldn't
wouldn't necessarily think about yeah so
number one is um getting to know the
chef uh which in most cases is the place
the person who's placing the orders and
you know who's who's who's after all the
user of our app so it's completely
different from the manager that you
normally see
is the first thing so understanding the
the who the real person is
fun fun fact about katu for the last
year we've been working inside of
restaurants so in our madrid office the
team needs to go through the kitchen
every day to get into their tables which
is quite unique it was our
sixth user if i'm not mistaken or fifth
and so you know we we basically decided
on the setup now that we're growing the
team unfortunately we need to leave that
is the first one second it's really
about how messy supply deliveries are
um because you know something that you
would you would find amazing is that
supplies are constantly coming in like
the average restaurant has 10 15
suppliers and they came in at the first
one at 8 a.m second one at 10 a.m when
you're already doing veggie shopping
third one at 12 where you're already
serving the first meals and and they
come and you just tell them to go to go
upstairs and leave it somewhere um and
so right that is something that you only
understand once you know the industry
and you understand the pain because
people in the in the restaurants can't
even check that you know what it was
delivered is actually what they ordered
so that is the second one and third one
is it's crazy but michael like really
crazy how much
people work in the industry and how much
effort they dedicate it's an incredibly
tough job
um that is you know many times
overlooked but that i deeply deeply
respect i've always been like that i'm
the sort of nerd guy with a lot of
notion guides of all the restaurants
that i've been to broken by persons and
everything
but now i'm and i felt you know
i felt even more in love with the people
who work in the industry which i deeply
deeply admire and we had chefs that uh
came to work at katu and for example
because they felt so in love with our
product that they they wanted to
evangelize it but i also know that it's
because their old job is just it's very
tough that a lot of people can handle it
very very cool and you go i really
appreciate you taking the time to come
and share your perspective and insights
with me i have a few a few short last
questions and i want you to take me back
to your childhood and what what really
fascinated you as a kid you know before
tech before investments before startups
what really fascinated you yeah so this
one will sound a bit strange but it's a
mix between history and geopolitics
maybe it's because of the fact that i'm
portuguese and you know our history has
always shown us that like being close to
the sea and also the fact that we
couldn't expand through land because we
were close to spain uh which was you
know a more powerful empire to say so at
the time we had no other chance but to
go
look out for the world and that's why we
opened like the first real big um uh
trade route to india and we disrupted
the silk road and so i was always very
passionate about
i mean or sort of fermented by this and
then i got passionate about geopolitics
and how geography really shaped
countries in the way that you know they
they designed their strategies and their
empires i really really liked it and i
still really like it and spend read a
lot of books about it to be honest
very very cool and what inspires you
today in your daily life yeah so
the sort of cliche
answer
but that is true in the one hand is
chefs
um and the restaurant entrepreneurs that
i work with
it's crazy the speed that which you know
you can go from being the hottest thing
in town to
shutting down in a year and i'm not even
talking about corona i'm just talking
about because strengths change at such a
fast pace but also i would also go as
far as saying and some people this is a
bit you know some people don't
understand this but like
high-level athletes especially football
players normally you know there's
there's this sort of like intellectual
feeling around like football 22 people
plus four referees running around the
ball but you know
i played football myself when i was
younger
and i deeply deeply and i admire someone
who at the age of 18 19
goes from in many cases like complicated
backgrounds to complete starlight and
you can be a star from one day to the
other and the following day you get
injured and you're on the bench for god
knows how long to me the career of these
sort of athletes it's very similar to to
the founders careers and you know i i i
really really respect it and it's
something that normally in this tech
world you sort of see some you know
disconnection with it and sort of like
uh intellectual sort of you know
superiority which i fully disagree i i
think that
people have different sort of virtues
and you just need to understand them and
respect them
very very cool and what are three words
you would choose to describe yourself
okay
first one is executor
i get it done no matter what and i fall
in love with the less sexy it is the
more i fall in love with
passionate i get incredibly obsessed
with
problems to be solved
and the last one which um it's ambition
like i'm very very ambitious uh always
have been always will be
and you know i believe great companies
can be built anywhere in the world no
matter the country the background
whatever you just need to keep on having
people who are just as hungry as you are
smarter than you are and with a notive
attitude someone who's willing to do you
know whatever
whatever you ask them to do
as long as it is solving problems
amazing amazing diego thank you so much
this was wonderful
thank you for the time and energy and
stay safe and stay healthy thank you it
was a pleasure